mit ihren einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünschte ihnen viel vergnügen
[Musik]
wir kommen auf den kulturplatz wir
schauen heute nach hongkong oder
schweizer kunstsammler uli sigg seine
immense sammlung zeitgenössischer
chinesischer kunst einem öffentlichen
museum vermacht hat
[Musik]
ja was denn früheren schweizer
botschafter antreibt und mit welchen
enormen auch politischen schwierigkeiten
zu kämpfen hatte das alles erzählen wir
ihnen gleich und widmen dieser reportage
unsere ganze sendezeit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
natürlich
hat mir wirklich und die werkliste gehen
wird vor nationale sicherheitsgesetz
angestellten wie möglich sind zeigen
es erwartet sie das universum politik
[Musik]
die gesamte politische prominenz war
gekommen um die eröffnung des neuen
museums enplus in hongkong zu feiern
mittendrin der schweizer politik seine
kunstsammlung ist der grundstein für das
größte museum für asiatische kunst und
kultur
[Musik]
wir sind am an die firma langer marsch
eines bildes der chinesische 16 pläne
und irgendwo zwischen leipzig und der iv
reform
will das ist fantastisches museum mit
schweizer herz und dramatisch und
euphorie jetzt präsentation vertreten
angegeben dass man durch ist wie das bis
jetzt noch nie ziehen
[Musik]
diese collection ist endlich da
angekommen wo sie hin sollte
in china
auch wenn die zeiten für feuerkunst
schwierig sind in hongkong
vor allem wenn sie so politisch ist wie
in der samt musik
[Musik]
natürlich
hat mir wirklich und die werkliste die
em wird fordern nationale
sicherheitsgesetz damals stellten die
möglichkeit zeigen und die eu stelle
sowie plan treiber weniger und natürlich
sehr viel diskussion braucht sehr viel
schlauer aber sowas einzeln jahr
bedeutet dass relativ viele leute
bis die richter also wie geplant intakt
blieben nicht
[Musik]
sick hat schon sehr früh die kunst
zusammengetragen die in china entweder
verboten oder ignoriert wurde
wenn er jetzt kunst zeigt die das
massaker vom tiananmen-platz
thematisiert oder eine installation des
künstlers ai weiwei der in china tabu
ist dann bewegte sich auf einem schmalen
grat
problem
natürlich
provokation ist für philipp
und den gesang privat war inhaltlich
sind wir aber als provokativ punkte
werden von einer minderheit aber die
menschen trotzdem egal betrifft in
hongkong und die stimmung ist angespannt
der regierungsvertreter hongkongs
bezeugte bei der eröffnung gehorsam
gegenüber peking
die eröffnung des museums im plus heißt
nicht dass die künstlerische freiheit
über dem gesetz steht
sie tut es nicht
dies ist die geschichte eines schweizer
diplomaten der ganz undiplomatisch schon
in den 90er jahren die studios der
chinesischen künstler besuchte und dort
sehr lange unter dem radar der
chinesischen behörden blieb
[Musik]
ein sehr fleißiger prozess steckt viel
offen hinter
sich für mich neuland aber aus auggen
willi toni sie kommen wir haben lieber
türen die wellen umstand und wie sie
denn sogar kunstsprache wenn auch ich
ganz grün und die ganze linie format die
normale materialien ganz schlecht
einfach wenn sie auch gar nicht gemacht
sie sind damit sie operiert wirkt
sondern die sind gemacht sind zeigen
vielleicht einmal ein tag im untergrund
muss stelle aber sicher nicht für mehr
sechs karriere in china begann in den
80er jahren als er für die firma
schindler das erste joint venture mit
einer westlichen firma aufbaute
schon damals reiste durchs ganze land
in den 90er jahren wurde er dann
schweizer botschafter in peking erst da
fing an sich auch für die kunst zu
interessieren
ich bin eigentlich verbrannt nacht zu
der künste gang tagsüber
realwirtschaft und wie sie da big
stunden nach das
1981 chinesisches früheren will die sind
immer für die feierlichkeiten am 60 ob
katze
und deshalb auch die sind angesprungen
gegangen und ich bin häufig
zurückgegangen auf botschaft und
irgendwo anders westlichsten 8 sek und
die zähne nicht einmischen dieser tag
setzt am gegen rheine gefahren und
hatten die künstler prof
sie schaute dorthin wo sonst niemand hin
guckte ins inoffizielle china
[Musik]
hofft nach quelle hat vielleicht ahnen
können und will in der regel hat ein
ausländer da braucht mir zum beispiel
chinesisch die wohl nichts gesagt
dass ich ein kleines bild machen die
jetzige chinese
diplomatische oder akademische oder
offizieller reise versteht überhaupt
leitet
[Musik]
nach einem jahrzehnt hertha-sieg die
einzige sammlung zeitgenössischer
chinesischer kunst zusammengetragen
2005 zeigt er sie im kunstmuseum bern an
solch provokativer einblick ins in
richters gab es selten sie wurde zur
brücke zwischen ost und west
er ist in china wie ein heiliger
wenn künstler über ihn reden ist der
teil ihrer familie lebt
er ist wie ein lehrer eine orientierung
in der kunst und wählt ganz persönlich
aus
siek erschuf den ersten chinesischen
kunstpreis und brachte die künstler vom
reich der mitte an die biennale in
venedig
nur in china selbst blieb die kunst im
untergrund
dieser gesamteindruck wäre auch für ein
chinesisches publikum neu und es müde wo
auch einen chinesischen publikum zeigen
wozu
experimentelle kunst gegenwarts kunst
fähig ist
doch china war noch weit davon entfernt
eine solche ausstellung im eigenen land
zuzulassen
[Musik]
als der künstler ebay 2011 verhaftet und
verprügelt wurde angeblich wegen
steuerhinterziehung wird sich klar
meinungsfreiheit wird es nicht so
schnell geben
pineda leidet an westerwelle zeige und
jetzt ist die richtige mäßig sie das
vorgebracht integrierte
prinzip ein prozess über inter triumph
als erwartet
stellte danach seine 80 tägige haft in
einer installation nach
[Musik]
hongkong anfang der 2000er jahre
die stadt baut auf einem aufgeschütteten
stück land einen kulturbezirk im zentrum
soll das museum im plus stehen was fehlt
ist eine gewichtige sammlung asiatischer
kunst
[Musik]
wien es ist natürlich so dass die
sammlung spacing gott verlässt shanghai
und ich habe viel sprachgefühl
company kulturministerium auf der ebene
stadtregierung und habe dann aber im
eigentlichen das größte hindernis
vorgefunden im regen auf einer
klagewelle leiden
wo liegt die klinik was ist die zensur
ganz genau wie wird die umgang mit der
sammlung und
plötzlich bin ich froh hongkongs
kontaktiert worden zu sein habe ich mich
dann für hongkong
hongkong schien die ideale lösung teil
von china aber mit rede- und
meinungsfreiheit
das war 2012 doch dann ändert sich alles
die demokratiebewegung wird von chinas
zentralregierung niedergeschlagen das
nationale sicherheitsgesetz wird
eingeführt und die freie presse
untersagt
unabhängige zeitungsverleger wie jimmy
lee werden ins gefängnis gesteckt
natürlich hält sich bis dramatische
andere 2012 und das
nationale sicherheitsgesetz
das sind ganz neue spielregeln
stark betroffen das heißt man darf nicht
mit zwei wochen die zur rezession also
zum abfall für hohen komfort mutterland
für mit der polizei
quasi das mutterland ist oft mit hass
erwecke das mutterland und will das
kreuz magisch damit aus eignet durch csu
breit anwenden und das hydraulik zum
schweizer braucht
besuch bei der galerie blind spot
hier hat sich früher schon kunstwerke
gekauft
heute ist die stimmung in hongkong
gedrückt die galerien können zwar noch
kunst ausstellen doch nur kunst die
peking nicht provozieren könnte
[Musik]
künstler versuchen zu verstehen was sie
sagen dürfen und was nicht
es herrscht ein zunehmendes bewusstsein
was als illegal gilt ist sehr vage das
heißt bis jetzt herrscht schweigen
wieder vergangenheit hängt natürlich die
hongkonger galerie sehr viel zeit in
mein land können die zeiger hört muss
mit der folge dass die griechen oder
vielleicht strengere richtlinien gelten
china sei aber chantals ohne
sicherheitsgesetze wie das jetzt in
hongkong für hongkong port moniert
worden ist aber er weiß gar nicht wie
das ganz genau geändert wird und von
details in alle
zurückhaltend doch sechs sammeltrieb
lässt nicht nach auch in diesen zeiten
findet er etwas was ihm gefällt
durchaus interessant finden will das
eigentlich zu hat mit meiner sammlung so
wenig sie hat fortsetzen
das ist ein ort wo die ganze
kommunikation geschichte ihnen passt wo
nicht gesammelt
zügen ist
interpretationen kreativ verschiedenen
phasen wo china gegangen ist mit dem
satelliten aus gebiete grenzen und die
großen chinesischen feier wo wie sie
heißt wo es internet klasse abschließt
überwunden und bremsen hitze bedeutet im
heutigen china
sechs vorherrschaft auf dem chinesischen
kunstmarkt ist nicht zu übersehen das
stößt auch auf kritik
[Musik]
wie kann ein westler darüber bestimmen
was für gute oder schlechte chinesische
kunst gehalten wird
die diskussion einbruch in das rezept
braucht es die chinesische entstanden
das ist eigentlich
viel weiß dominanz unterschiedlicher
beschäftigung
wir sind überall ein
punkt der business diplomatie sehr
geschichte fabrik wurde bis zum
president und
dass wir eigentlich am schluss das
verständnis brachten das heißt diese hat
auch nach über 7
inzwischen ist sein netzwerk in china so
groß dass man kaum mehr um ihn herum
kommt in sachen kunst
er hat die tür geöffnet die
zeitgenössische chinesische kunst in die
welt zu bringen
und dabei den künstlern sammlern und
kritik an chinas die augen geöffnet
vor allem der sieg kunstpreis hat bis
heute einen enormen einfluss in der
kunstwelt
[Applaus]
lonsee
in der nähe von luzern
hier besitzt sie kann schloss inklusive
insel und ziel
sein einfluss auf chinas kunstwelt ist
jedes jahr während der art basel spürbar
dann geht er auch auf sein anwesen das
er 1990 er jahren erworben hat
[Musik]
im militär schmalz geschichte wo
soldaten
wir sind die in europa wir haben sechs
stammen gehören wahlkampf vielen dank
das schon ganz speziell ihre geschäfte
am see begangen haben
in china derzeit sieht die krise
zufällig das und fisch und dann wohnt
ist ein reines hobby ja sonst
[Musik]
auf seinem schloss sehen sammler aus ost
und west meistens zum ersten mal was
china alles zu bieten hat das mitten in
der schweiz
gerade für die chinesischen sammler
spricht das dafür dass sich beziehungen
nach ganz oben hat
die schon jetzt begeistert will
besser also league geschafft die
vorarbeit mit dem sc und dass interna
ausstieg gekommen weil die chinesen also
die eine seite muss man sehen wie gut
die bezirke zu regieren kann dass das
eine sehr ehrliche berater so aber an
die tritte
nicht
erkennen
der
umgang mit den armen ist natürlich ein
anderes
[Musik]
damit
hongkong 2018
nach sechsjähriger bauzeit ist erst der
rohbau des museums m + fertig
doch sieg verschafft sie schon einen
eindruck wo seine sammlung in zukunft
hinkommen 14
es ist groß riesig
auf der anderen seite auch noch
hinter der mauer dann diese da diese
zwei und eine dritte dort alles zusammen
sieben galerien
manche sind noch unterteilt
geplant war die fertigstellung des
gebäudes auf 2019 vor der einführung des
nationalen sicherheits gesetzes da hätte
sich noch die möglichkeit gehabt aus dem
projekt auszusteigen
also
dass sie wenn das museum
[Musik]
es ist also stetig die dimension rom an
bevor die tramperin zeichnen ist
entsetzlich
26 braucht
für sein spiel
[Musik]
damals waren die einschränkungen der
kunstfreiheit in hongkong noch nicht
abzusehen
der bau wurde entworfen von den
schweizer architekten herzog de meuron
musik kennt die beiden gut
das museum gehört mit 65.000
quadratmetern zu den größten weltweit
für den entwurf entscheidend war eine
zugstrecke die unter dem museum
hindurchführt
cartoon was ich das eigentlich nur wenig
sagen dass da und unterirdische
infrastruktur wollen der touristischen
infrastruktur
wort wurzeln bildet und dann kurz auf
den schwaben der deckel drüber dass eine
archäologische roddick und die abdecken
das waren die körper der auf inhalte die
traditionelle ausstellungsräumen und von
dort rüber ist denn du dich liebe nach
der hoch ist dass ich 100 meter riese
screen eigentlich wo zu hongkong obere
eck
für herzog und dämmerung ist das museum
ein öffentlicher ort der begegnung und
wird in solche repressiven zeiten fast
schon zu einem politischen statement
architektonischer überlegungen sind
ausgerichtet nach offenheit nach dialog
nach begegnet ob sie glaubt nicht dass
sie schnell gemacht das kann ich nicht
beurteilen und das kann ja nicht stören
wollten das nationale sicherheitsgesetz
oft komisch vor zwischen natürlicher
corsi die wolke der natürlich den svi
offen oder lebendig hat ihre
institutionen ihre mission eigentlich
wohne und das können wir jetzt noch
nicht abschätzen
physik ist klar das museum ist ein ort
der debatte seine kunstwerke
reflektieren die fragen der zeit wie
viel individualismus ist in china
erlaubt und was bedeutet die rasante
entwicklung des landes für seine
bewohner
eine skulptur besteht aus menschlichem
fett und nennt sich
zivilisations säule
[Musik]
konsumgesellschaft
verantwortlich chinesische rufzeichen
tiefer armut formen entwicklungsland
unwahrscheinlich roche hat er eine
üppige konsumgesellschaft nicht für alle
aber doch für sehr viele
praktisch wird solche kunst dauerhaft zu
sehen sein was wenn der druck aus peking
zunimmt und werke wie das wohn floss des
hongkonger künstlers tracy wong verboten
würde nur weil er als dissident eben
erst nach thailand ausgewandert ist eine
öffentliche diskussion
gefordert worden ist dass verschiedene
argumente
also nicht dafür zeigt war der haushalt
wird verkauft werden aber bis jetzt ist
das alles mal einfach im ruhestand und
deswegen ihren reihen gemacht bis
verkaufen das war juristisch gar nicht
machbar also ich mir jetzt vernünftige
der hinsicht aber dass wenn nicht heiße
dass nicht wie die folgen im raum stehen
die eröffnungsausstellung jedenfalls
wurde noch nicht zensuriert
physik gilt aber vor allem die
langfristige perspektive für
mich warum die lange frist meinte da
kommt ganz ganz sicher um alles wir
können seite in hongkong der tag sich
selbst aber als parteilose nicht unter
kontrolle gehabt
es bleibt zu hoffen dass er recht behält
denn hongkong könnte für china das tor
zum westen sei und dafür braucht es eine
freie kunst
[Musik]
das war unsere reportage aus hongkong
und wenn sie noch mehr informationen
möchten über die sammlung sigg sei ihnen
die internetadresse des museums ein plus
wärmstens empfohlen wir beschäftigen uns
nächste woche mit dem thema tod und der
frage ob es trost gibt auch ohne glauben
und hier geht es jetzt gleich weiter auf
sf1 mit dem philosophischen stammtisch
und meiner kollegin barbara bleisch eine
gute woche für sie
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos